did you guys see the Chris Rock special
no I haven't seen that one yet but it's
definitely on the watch list I've seen a
few Clips but I haven't seen the whole
thing so
it's it's very gracious
right that's what I've heard yeah he
does and why wouldn't you I mean you
know Will Smith walked up to him on a
stage in front of the world
and he did nothing
um
he was raw back in the 90s so I'm glad
yeah well he hasn't caved to the I think
he's one of the best stand-ups or was I
mean the one that he did recently like
the stuff outside of the Chris Rock
stuff I didn't think it was that that
great you know to begin with but never
scared in my opinion is one of his best
stand-up comedies but the thing that
happened in this stand-up comedy on
Netflix was he basically used it as an
opportunity to pay back uh Will Smith
for what happened what I don't know what
was it like a year ago
yeah that was that was a great little
bit you can probably find it on the
interwebs it's it's something like maybe
eight to twelve minutes long but he but
he really lays in it but it's like you
know he's basically saying like look
dude
I didn't I didn't put this out there
it's like you and your wife sat down in
front of a table in front of the world
and talked about her cheating on you
with your son's best friend and you're
mad at me yeah because I say something
you had a publicist there yeah you had a
team a PR yeah you know what I mean
I think it sounds very familiar to the
situation that Megan and
yeah
he goes after he goes after them too in
the special actually yeah he does he
does yeah he goes after them too and I I
think that it's it's kind of like a um
this is what like American celebrities
have become is this kind of like you
know um red table talk kind of you know
cheating on your wife has the woman is
in charge and all she demands a limp
dick kind of [__] though right that's
kind of what you know is expected in
these Hollywood circles yeah yeah
they're like real life check Stan
tabloid magazines
it's it's brutal like I is is is Will
Will Smith still married to Jada Pinkett
Smith yeah I believe so he's still with
that hoe after all of that
yeah
that is two blocks Tupac's Alpha with a
yeah well maybe you know maybe we'll
come along and and swoop in and have a
story there I wouldn't doubt it
speaking of which the uh the other two
that shall not be mentioned uh South
Park recently did an episode on them
which is pretty funny and I think that I
think it pissed them off they were the
Canadian royalty though yeah that that
was actually one of the best episodes of
South Park apparently and um it's really
like right now like they're less popular
than uh prince Andrew the alleged
pedophile who was on uh Epstein's Island
like they are less popular than him yeah
so I think they got kicked out of their
house in the UK but wait uh Oprah
Winfrey likes them yeah she's from adult
free right wow
yeah she's a purveyor of Truth and yeah
absolutely apparently yeah but you know
I I think basically what it comes down
to is that um especially in
entertainment these things move on a
three or four year cycle right so if you
think back to three or four years ago
that's when the whole metoo thing was in
full swing and so that's why a lot of
these projects are coming out now so but
the success of stuff like top gun
Maverick and just other projects that
aren't super woke
um means that Hollywood is kind of or
entertainment in general is kind of
recognizing that this whole
um
is an abject failure and the Pendulum is
going to be swinging back it's just the
way that Hollywood or entertainment
works is that these things are in the
pipeline for maybe two or three years
and then there's a marketing so it's
probably going to be about another one
or two years before the pendulum kind of
swings back to to normal at least that's
what I've heard yeah it'd be nice to see
some good movies again I had a
conversation with someone down here
recently and actually a couple people
have asked me lately like what's wrong
with the US culture why don't you guys
make good movies anymore why don't you
guys put out good music what it's like I
don't know it's a larger sign of some
some sickness uh inside of our society I
suppose
yeah they used to knock out bangers and
like I mean when I was a kid 80s and 90s
right like they would knock out Banger
after Banger like Top Gun
um what was it with Tom Cruise with the
NASCAR uh Days of Thunder or something
like that yeah like they used to knock
out Banger after Banger it's just now
most of the stuff that I haven't gone to
the movie theater in ages
it's probably been well over a year like
even after they lifted the restrictions
I think I've seen maybe like one or two
films or something Top Gun was probably
the last one that I saw
I like going to the movie theater too I
I've had people ask me hey is it because
of kova did kovid Kill Cinema and I
always say no Cinema killed Cinema
there's there's a lot of good foreign
movies coming out my brother watches
like Russian war movies I know people
that watch Korean movies that really
like them Mexican Cinemas starting to
get better but the US
Cinema and just general pop culture has
been terrible for going on a decade now
even comedies you can't find good
comedies but back in like pre-2012 there
that Whole Decade or prior to 2012
there's a bunch of good comedies like
the Frat pack and the Those runs yeah
yeah ski ski school and all that sort of
stuff you know I've had a lot of
recommendations you know for my brother
because he because he's an avid like War
film sort of guy and he's like oh you
got to check out this war movie you got
to check this one it's like I'll go and
turn it on for five minutes and then I'm
either reading the movie because there's
subtitles or they've translated into
English and it's like a bad Japanese
like Kung Fu movie from like 40 years
ago where like the lip syncing doesn't
match up obviously it's like I'm not
reading a movie and I'm not watching
something where the lips don't sync up
to the dialogue it's like done I'm out
Vic it's annoying here I I always watch
the movies in original language so
usually they're predominantly in English
but out of habit I always have the
Spanish subtitles on because I usually
have Spanish-speaking company so that's
not as bad as when it's like Russian to
English but the thing is Spanish and
English that's that's a that should be a
pretty easy one to translate as compared
to like a Russian to English German to
English and they still screwed up all
the time I know it'll distract me that
I'll be listening to the English audio
track something's really funny and a lot
of times for to be funny that you have
to have specificity and you look at the
translation and it's so General and so
Broad and so vague that just it's it
just dies with any of my
Spanish-speaking audience around me so
that's that's always kind of tough too
with the uh the translation thing you
lose a lot in Translation so to speak I
really hope you guys enjoyed that clip
if you want to watch the full length
podcast you can find that over here that
clips from if you're new to the channel
make sure you hit subscribe over here
and pin down below in the top comment
you'll find a bunch of useful links to
my website my supplement line books and
a bunch of other stuff have an amazing
day peace so